the invasion of ukraine has hardened
europe's resolve to wean itself off
russian energy supplies to cut off a key
source of income for the kremlin today
the u.s announced a plan to supply
liquefied natural gas to the eu heather
urex west joins us now from washington
and heather will this be enough for
europe to move away from russian sources
jackson the short answer is no europe
just can't afford to do anything like
that even with the help being promised
from the u.s today and that's because
the numbers just don't add up europe
brings in more than 150 billion cubic
meters of natural gas from russia each
year the u.s is promising an additional
15 billion cubic meters that's just 10
percent of what's needed the u.s isn't
promising more because they can't
deliver it canada can't either there
isn't the infrastructure in place
because there hasn't been the investment
needed and this isn't something you can
change on a dime
these projects take billions of dollars
and they take years to do as canada has
experience takes sometimes a decade to
do
um so it might it might help in the
short term it feels good but it's not
going to displace russian gas 25
of the russian gas that we are getting
is non-replaceable we have
either to continue to finance
putin's war or we have to face recession
so it sounds like europe may have its
hands tied in the short term but could
that change
well putin's actions have certainly put
a pla plan in motion that will see
europe move away from russian energy as
quickly as they can germany released a
report today that would see its russian
imports cut in half by mid-summer with
the country completely off of russian
oil and gas by 2024
it is possible that markets need
certainty they need commitments from
customers that if they invest they will
see the return jackson heather yorks
west in washington thanks heather